in health news there are rising concerns
about an increase in colon cancer cases
among younger people the American Cancer
Society found that one out of every five
new cases of colorectal cancer in 2019
were in people under the age of 55 and
that is nearly double what the rate was
back in 1995. the report also found that
more patients under 65 are being
diagnosed with late stage or later stage
disease that's not good colon cancer is
the third most common cancer overall and
the third leading cause of
cancer-related fatalities for men and
women in the U.S CBS News chief medical
correspondent Dr John lapuke is also a
gastroenterologist at NYU langone and
the doctor for basically everyone I know
and care about yes hello my name is
we're very happy with our doctor by the
way yes my wife is as well thank you
very much for being here
um so a doubling in the rate of cancer
for younger people here what's going on
well we don't really know there are a
lot of suspects but you know the actual
villain isn't clear is it the fact that
we are more obese because obesity is a
risk factor more sedentary something in
the environment something we're eating
or drinking or fascinating to me is the
microbiome the trillions of bacteria
thousands of species in our colon it
looks like there may be a relationship
or a microbiome is changing and that may
be contributing to the increase boy so
but if you don't know what's causing it
it's hard to know what you do as a
person to help reduce your risk well you
get screened so that is why you know
they have dropped the the age that you
first get screened if you're at average
risk from 50 down to 45 and that's the
reason why they said well you know
polyps are sitting there for years
totally benign and if you take it out
and that polyp was destined to become
cancer you don't get cancer instead of
getting cancer so what they're doing is
lowering the screen years ago you found
a pile because I first went to you in
2016 you found something yeah you
removed it yeah it was but had it not
been removed it could it could it could
have over over time and again you're
you're the one revealing this I would
never reveal it just
nut about this I'm very very
confidential and you know since you're
saying it yes you're a perfect example
Gail you know you had a small adenomous
pulp those are the kind that are totally
benign it could have been in there for
years doing nothing but gradually over
years it had the potential to turn into
cancer we took it out and that's the end
of it but you know there's no family
history of colon cancer in my family my
son is now 35 and I'm now saying will
you should go get a colonoscopy what's
the downside to getting one at a younger
age when you see the cases are going up
in people that are young yeah you know I
know it's tempting to say that it just
went from 50 to 45 there are risks to
doing any procedure there are expenses
uh and you have to think about what's
the risk benefit of all that but I think
that if you are a younger person one of
the messages here is you know if you're
if you are 35 and you're not yet getting
screened for whatever reason uh then you
could say well what are the symptoms you
know they're changing the stool uh
rectal bleeding uh lost weight loss for
an unexplained reason abdominal cramping
and iron deficiency anemia so if you're
told of a low iron and there's no
obvious explanation then that's
something that your health care provider
should help evaluate and you know one of
the things you can do is do a test of
the school to see do you have invisible
blood in the stool wow so I was happy to
come to you also Dr LeBron my wife was
like how can you go to a doctor who you
also work with I'm like that's the best
part I got over that very quickly very
quickly but if you are not comfortable
with an in-person exam are there
alternative tests available there are
you know there are you the at-home stool
tests you know you've heard that sounds
more gross
right with the dancing people uh do you
like those you know it's a good test
it's a good alternative test the best
test is the one that you do cologord
works by testing for a combination of
invisible blood and also the shedding of
genetic material from polyps and colon
cancer it's better at picking up colon
cancer it's pretty good uh than than
picking up uh colon polyp but they're
also Imaging tests you can do other
things you can do all right Dr John the
Poo always great to have you at the
table we appreciate it and see you in
the in the briefing room as well the
exam room exam room always there doctor